BUKOLA AYODELE:
Today, we're talking
about Cloud Function, security,
and where to store things.
I'm Bukola, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Cloud Functions is a
lightweight platform
for creating standalone
functions, which
is a great way to create
pieces of a larger workflow.
With the newly launched ability
to specify the minimum number
of instances, you no longer
need to worry about cold starts
delaying your workflows.
Try it out for yourself
with the linked tutorial.
Speaking of Cloud
Functions, did you
know it now has
native integration
with Secret Manager?
Secret Manager is a fully
managed storage system
for keeping secrets like
API keys or passwords.
These two great services
are even better together.
So check out how you can get
better at keeping a secret.
The sooner you think
about security,
the less downstream issues
you're likely to have.
That is why it can help to have
an on-demand scanning setup
as part of your CI/CD process.
You can read more about
how on-demand scanning can
help detect vulnerabilities
in containers
and follow along in
tutorials to stay secure.
While you may not be able to
move all those boxes in garage
to Cloud Storage, it's a perfect
solution for object storage
no matter what your
application needs.
If you're not sure which storage
class or location to use,
don't worry, Priyanka
breaks it down
in this quick sketchnote
and blog post.
If you want to read
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or idea, leave
a comment or tweet us,
and we'll see you in the Cloud.